Rainbow six siege is a team game and
your mileage will vary from night
tonight depending largely on your fellow
player skill level communication and
ability to pick the right operators at
the right time each new DLC brings with
it two new operators in a map that have
the potential to drastically alter
player tactics and team play we went
hands-on with velvet shell the start of
sieges year to content hit that
subscribe button and let's talk about
the impact of this dlc for eliminated
friendly mission successful first up the
operator duo the new attacker is jackal
who's designed to sniff out those really
stubborn roamers defenders who venture
away from the objective and wait to
ambush entry teams from behind his I
Knox model 3 which is a better name than
forehead snobs vision I suppose it's
right on his forehead can be turned on
to see defender footprints we were told
after the event that he can also scan
those footprints to reveal the location
of a defender every 15 seconds for one
minute but in the course of our demo we
rarely saw footprints much less handler
whether or not this is actually useful
as a toss up most teams will have
already scouted for roamers with their
drones and staring at the floor knowing
rumors are present is a sure way to get
you shot you know staring at the floor
his low that includes the new c70
assault rifle the PDW 9 and the ITA 12 l
and ITA 12s shotguns in English he has
some really good hardware and functions
as a fast attacker we used his PDW 9
with its respectable fire rate and 50
round drum plus the new shotgun in the
pistol slot to poke holes and peek into
objective rooms sorry buck your things
getting a little less important he's a
good fit for players who are not as
gadget focus as their counterparts and
can quickly see if anyone's been in a
room then move on we even used his
weapon to turn the tables on mirror a
few times
Mira is the new defender she's a lady
who says to herself what's on the other
side of that wall and then installs a
big honking one-way window she has the
potential to change the way attacking
teams move on objectives knowing that
they're being watched and can't do much
about it they can no longer just shoot
out a camera and go back to anonymity
the Black Mirror gadget can be set into
walls or heavy barricades it can be
opened only once by smashing a gas
cylinder at the base and when the window
lowers it makes a lot of noise alerting
attackers that it's about to happen this
gadget will be a bit frightening to come
across on ground level objectives such
as the garages on house and consulate it
did seem to be destructible with habanos
launcher but we were not able to shoot
through with class it's also one of
those gadgets that can be used by anyone
on your team even after you're dead with
all that being said once the mirrors
open it stays open and attackers can
just as easily use it to shoot into the
room so you know that breeze kind of
blows both ways Mira also has the ITA
12s shotgun in her pistol slot which is
really good at making murder holes that
she can exploit with a savage 1200 round
per minute vector 45 ACP the vectors
magazine only holds 25 rounds though so
don't miss
it expired we spent two hours with the
new operators on the new coastline map
with your main course of death comes a
side dish of Mediterranean tunes car
vandalism and gorgeous ocean views look
at this car dude
hope they have insurance one interesting
feature of the map is that it has an
interior open courtyard that counts is
inside for defenders so they're not
marked as usual even though technically
outside it's a medium-sized building
with multiple floors and a breath of
fresh tactical air if you didn't like
the speed of favela or clutter of
skyscraper ultimately velvet shell is a
DLC providing one attacker for running
gun players and one defender for
tactical players mirror will probably
have a greater impact on the game on a
wider variety of mass as your two goes
into full swing I'm still curious how
releasing and balancing a new operators
will play out do you just end up solving
the problems of one operator by adding
another operator the other big
unanswered question to which I did not
get a straight reply is if this game
will introduce more situations or
single-player content all day enough our
embargo sheet said not to spoil the end
missions or cutscenes but we didn't see
end missions and new DLC characters of
late have not had cut scenes will keep
pushing for an answer to that in the
meantime if you like our tactical
coverage go check out our hands-on
impression with Ghost Recon wildlands
six things we learn are you going to go
play C's for another year or are you
going to wait for a sequel what do you
think about the direction of the game as
it goes into year two let us know what
you want to see us cover next in the
comments below and thanks for watching
five
for eliminating mission successful